I think when you first got your break
you were working part-time as a churro
guy at the LA Zoo is that correct
yeah I mean that you were that was a
that was the job you held while you were
shooting which movie American pop yeah
why shot we shot American Pie night and
that I like work like six days on the
movie oh you know I write and and then
afterwards I'm like I was hopeful I was
like you know I think this movie's gonna
be great I don't know if it's gonna get
me another movie so I had to get a job
and my friend was like I work at the zoo
man it's awesome you get to like feed
the animals and feed the monkeys and
like this sounds amazing and I got a job
there and they I was the churro guy yeah
so to make the churros yeah and I was
like oh this sucks right and then I
remember the second day I was working
there we were doing an interview for for
Rolling Stone
for American Pie I thought you know
that's cool you know and remember set
them with the interviewer he's like we
have going on right now I'm like well
I'm a amateur oh guy at the LA Zoo he
goes that's interesting what does that
come out I'm like the churro guys we
have a clip here from bloodline and I
compliment you you are you're pretty
chilling in this this is really yeah
yeah this is it is a fun movie you do a
fantastic job and this is a this is an
intense film I think people were really
going to enjoy it anything we know and
we need to know for this setup for this
cliff well it's just at the moment where
this policeman detective shows up he
starts ask me some questions to start
and put some things together yes yeah
and it's beautifully uncomfortable let's
take a look at this clip from bloodline
all my clients are children at risk
many of them have problematic family
lives drug abuse criminality mental
illness often their family members are
at risk themselves
our school is a regional high school
with over 5,000 students yeah well we
have several options and we're looking
into right now how long have you been a
counselor there social worker a little
over a year are you saying you think
that I might have something to do with
this it raises some red flags yeah mom
was like I don't know if I really know
who you are
yeah